- Hi, I'm Rob Lowe.
- We're here at the
promo shoot right now
where Rob's getting
all dolled up
to help promote his
own tongue lashing.
- You know, people talk
about honors in this town.
Golden Globes, the
Emmys, the Oscars.
The Comedy Central Roast
trumps all of them.
(upbeat music)
David, have you seen your
little girl outfit yet?
Where are you?
David Spade?
- Hey Sexy.
- What are you
doing in my bedroom?
- Nothing.
- I've been asking David Spade
to do the roast for so long.
- Oh man, I'm so glad
you're doing this.
- I know, it's safety
in numbers, right?
- We go way, way back.
We've been in the
trenches together.
He's got some stories I
hope that he does not share.
- I have to figure out a
way to really shit on him.
Gracefully.
- When I do these
types of things,
it's like going to battle.
I will hang up
pictures of Rob Lowe
from every movie and TV
show he's ever been in.
- I see a couple that I
didn't have on my wall here.
Austin Powers?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Huh?
Huh? Huh?
Macho.
Huh?
- [David] Cycles, yeah.
That's the PR team going
scramble, scramble,
make him look tougher.
Throw a motorcycle in.
The problem with jokes
with him are like,
are all really compliments.
(laughter)
- I never thought it
would happen to me.
When I was a kid
growing up in Ohio,
my goals were to
become an actor,
to star in movies, to
have a long career,
and to be made fun of by people
who are a lot uglier than I am.